actor James Franco says sexual
misconduct allegations against him are
not accurate he addressed the social
media claims on CBS's Late Show with
Stephen Colbert last night at least two
accusers came forward after he won a
Golden Globe Award on Sunday he wore a
pen promoting a new campaign to fight
sexual harassment and gender
discrimination the time's up pen
Jericka Duncan is here with the latest
big name in Hollywood to be accused of
misconduct Rico good morning good
morning the New York Times canceled a
panel discussion featuring Franco which
was supposed to take place tonight
now the question surrounding James
Franco's conduct with women didn't begin
at the Golden Globes but it picked up
momentum following the award show Late
Show host Stephen Colbert pressed Franco
on his decision to wear a times up pin
and the accusations that follow you got
criticized for wearing that do you know
why and and and what what do you have a
response everything you want to say
about that criticism well first I
wouldn't say I wore because I do support
it appearing on Tuesdays Late Show with
Stephen Colbert actor James Franco
addressed the sexual misconduct
allegations that surfaced online this
week there were some things on Twitter
today yeah I didn't I didn't I haven't
read them I've heard about them James
Franco following Franco's appearance and
Golden Globe victory Sunday a number of
women spoke out against him including
actress Ally Sheedy who in a now-deleted
tweet appeared to write James Franco
just one please never ever ask me why I
left the film TV business and actress
violet Paley who tweeted cute times up
pen James Franco remembered the time you
pushed my head down in a car towards
your exposed penis I have no idea what I
did the ally sheedy I directed her in a
play off Broadway I had nothing but a
great time with her total respect for
her I had no I have no idea why she was
upset she took the tweet down I don't I
don't know the things that I heard that
were on Twitter are not accurate but
I completely support people coming out
and being able to have a voice because
they didn't have a voice for so long so
I don't want to I don't want to you know
shut them down in any way it's it's I
think a good thing and I support it we
reached out to both Franco and the women
mentioned in this story but have yet to
hear back
thanks tariqa it's one of those things
where he scheduled the interview I'm
sure long before the Golden Globes and
then this happens and he honored his
commitment but it sure sounds like he
still has some explaining to do
yeah I thought they handled it very well
yeah he did it got a lot of good answers
yeah we write to him mm-hmm Eureka